[Música]
hola bienvenidos aquí américa el espacio
de france 24 en el que revisamos en
profundidad las noticias de nuestro
continente
soy valentina torres sánchez en
reemplazo de mi compañera natalia
cabrera y estos son nuestros temas de
hoy
el presidente de haití yo en el móvil
fue asesinado las autoridades en el país
hicieron un llamado a la calma en una
nación que ya estaba sumergida en una
profunda crisis política
en bolivia para atraer a la población
aymara generalmente reticente a la
medicina moderna los médicos de la paz
sumaron fuerzas con una naturista y una
chamán para tratar el kobe 19
pero simon se convirtió en la primera
indígena canadiense en la historia en
ser elegida como gobernadora general al
tiempo que en el país hay un debate por
el racismo estructural tras el
descubrimiento de cientos de fosas de
niños nativos que eran educados en
centros católicos y vamos de inmediato
con nuestra historia principal el
presidente de haití joven el movice fue
asesinado mientras estaba en su hogar la
primera dama también fue herida según
las autoridades haitianas 26 colombianos
y dos haitianos estadounidenses son los
responsables bogotá inició una
investigación pero que pasó en haití
antes de la muerte de maurice el país ya
presentaba una profunda inestabilidad
precisamente por su permanencia en el
poder
sus detractores argumentaban que ya
había terminado su mandato mientras que
el presidente justificaba que aún había
cerca de seis meses pendientes lo cierto
es que ya había un calendario electoral
para reemplazarlo les contamos más en el
siguiente informe
a principios de 2021 haití vivió una ola
de protestas los ciudadanos que ya
estaban movilizándose en las calles
permanentemente desde 2018 tomaron un
nuevo aliento luego de que rubén el mois
no reconociera que había llegado el
final de su mandato y es que según moix
el mandato de cinco años terminaba hasta
2022 ya que si bien ganó las elecciones
por primera vez en octubre de 2015 su
victoria en las urnas fue anulada por lo
que los haitianos votaron nuevamente y
el tomo posesión de ese mandato en 2017
pero para la oposición en el mandato de
moix terminaba el 7 de febrero de 2021
ya que cuenta los 5 años desde su
primera victoria en 2015
los detractores de moix lo señalaban
además por corrupción en un escándalo
ligado a desvíos de dineros prestados
por venezuela a través de la operación
petrocaribe un proyecto del ex
presidente venezolano hugo chávez para
que los países del caribe accedieran a
petróleo a precios preferenciales cuando
salió a la luz el desvío de estos fondos
y estallaron las protestas
moix destituyó a su primer ministro
eso no silencio a los manifestantes que
pedían la renovación total del gobierno
y mejor acceso a empleo salud educación
y seguridad
moix había llegado a gobernar con la
promesa de abrir un nuevo capítulo en la
historia de la nación pero bajo su
mandato la nación de más de 11 millones
de personas se ha hecho cada vez más
inestable haití fue la primera nación de
américa en independizarse en 1791 pero
la inestabilidad política el azote de la
naturaleza en el terremoto de 2010 y el
paso del huracán matthew en 2014 han
empeorado la ya precaria situación de
sus ciudadanos
el gobierno de bolivia acusó al
expresidente argentino mauricio macri de
enviar armas a su país durante la crisis
de 2019 que terminó con la renuncia del
entonces mandatario de evo morales y la
posterior asunción de jeanine áñez el
actual presidente argentino alberto
fernández ofreció disculpas en nombre
del pueblo pero resaltamos
que la argentina presidida por mauricio
macri le dio a las fuerzas militares que
reprimieron la protesta social el año en
noviembre de 2019
mi misión
letal el 13 de noviembre de 2019 se lo
agradecieron
el 15 de noviembre de 2019
dos días después se producía la masacre
destacado
seguimos en bolivia porque médicos
tradicionales y naturistas suman sus
conocimientos para vencer el rechazo de
los indígenas a los tratamientos
modernos contra el coronavirus nuestra
corresponsal en la paz mery vaca nos
cuenta más es un día importante para
teresa huanca y su madre angélica mamani
un equipo médico anti cobit 19 visita a
su comunidad algo poco usual siempre el
interés que tenía era que yo no quería
salir pero mi mamá me ha traído y me
está en los médicos siempre
para atraer a la población aymara
normalmente reticente al tratamiento con
medicina moderna los médicos de la paz
sumaron fuerzas con una naturista que
trabaja con hierbas y una chamán que
hace ritos en hojas de coca es que hay
flemas
no puede votar con este lampacitos le
vas a poner aquí esfuerzo ese día de la
fecha del cumpleaños hay que volver a
bendecir a nuestros hijos ya a muchas
personas se les aplicó pruebas para
detectar kobe y la mayoría salió
negativa es el caso de carmen cayó que
creyó estar infectada y durante un mes
se trató solo con hierbas
es una alegría para mí porque me ha
alejado en incluso muchos
distanciamientos como insectos
sin embargo la doctora yesenia ríos
halló casos positivos y advirtió que la
medicina naturista tiene límites ante
casos graves todo lo natural funciona
pero en una etapa en la cual la carga
viral es baja y tierna paciente
necesitada ya tiene dificultades
respiratorias y entiende que le falta el
oxígeno esto es natural no ayuda mucho
y así con la buena voluntad de esta
brigada médica que respeta los valores
culturales de los aymaras y debido a la
pandemia la medicina moderna llega al
campo y a sus residentes las pruebas
para detectar el coronavirus están
hechas ahora falta saber cuándo llegará
la vacunación
vamos a eeuu donde una nueva encuesta
muestra la diferencia en la vacunación
de los ciudadanos con base en su
afiliación política y revela que es muy
poco menos probable que los republicanos
que aún no lo han hecho consideren
vacunarse frente a los demócratas en la
misma situación y con la variante delta
propagándose ahora en la unión americana
esto puede ser un peligro
eeuu da pasos inmensos en la lucha
contra el hobbit 19 sin embargo el
presidente joe biden está decepcionado
ya que el país no alcanza un objetivo
clave de vacunación
todos sabemos que han surgido variantes
poderosas como la variante delta por
favor si no se ha vacunado hágalo hágalo
ahora para usted para sus seres queridos
para su comunidad y para su país
en mayo baiden estableció una meta que
el 70% de los estadounidenses haya
recibido al menos una dosis de la vacuna
para el 4 de julio pero en realidad esa
cifra alcanza sólo alrededor del 67 por
ciento baiden también quería que 160
millones de adultos estuvieran
completamente vacunados pero se quedó
corto en tres millones y mejorar esas
cifras podría ser una dura batalla una
encuesta reciente del washington post y
abc muestra una marcada división
política frente a las vacunas el 86% de
los demócratas ha recibido al menos una
dosis y de los republicanos
el 45 por ciento y aunque el 6 por
ciento de los demócratas dicen que no es
probable que se vacunen entre los
republicanos ese número aumenta al 47%
los funcionarios en estados rojos como
alabama arkansas y west virginia
ahora están instando a sus electores a
arremangarse la camisa para hacerlo
muchos de los que dudan citan el rápido
desarrollo de las vacunas aunque creen
que el gobierno y los medios de
comunicación están exagerando el riesgo
de la variante delta eeuu ha registrado
más de 600.000 muertes por kobe y 19 más
de 200 estadounidenses todavía mueren a
causa de ella todos los días el
epidemiólogo más importante del país el
doctor anthony fauci dice que más del 99
por ciento de esas muertes se producen
entre los no vacunados
vamos a canadá para revisar la imagen de
la semana se trata de emery simon ella
es la primera indígena canadiense en ser
elegida como gobernadora general el
cargo ceremonial sirve como
representante oficial de la reina isabel
del reino unido la cita de sabemos llega
en un momento particularmente sensible
para los canadienses pues en los últimos
dos meses se han encontrado cientos de
tumbas de niños indígenas en antiguas
escuelas residenciales
niños túnicas tradicionales actúan en
una ceremonia cerca del sitio donde se
descubrieron 751 tumbas sin nombres el
grupo indígena que encontró los restos
tomará el control de sus propios
servicios de bienestar infantil en
virtud de un acuerdo firmado con el
gobierno federal
este es un paso importante hacia
adelante al final del día significará
menos juventud y niños en cuidados más
temprano trudeau había nombrado a la
primera gobernadora general indígena
maya point es el gestor que me cita es
histórica y un momento inspirador para
canadá y un paso importante en el largo
camino hacia la reconciliación
gration el país ha estado lidiando con
el legado de su trato a la comunidad
indígena la semana pasada se encontraron
los restos de 182 personas cerca de los
terrenos de una antigua escuela
residencial cerca de cranbrook columbia
británica el tercer descubrimiento de
este tipo en menos de dos meses los
hallazgos han despertado la indignación
nacional al menos una docena de iglesias
han sido incendiadas en las últimas
semanas y los manifestantes han
derribado estatuas de la reina isabel y
la reina victoria desde finales del
siglo 19 más de 150.000 niños indígenas
fueron matriculados por la fuerza en
internados gestionados por la iglesia y
financiados por el gobierno más de 4000
de ellos murieron de enfermedad
y negligencia otros fueron abusados
física y sexualmente
algunas de estas escuelas todavía
estaban en funcionamiento en 1996 hasta
la fecha no hay un recuento completo de
cuántos niños murieron las
circunstancias de sus muertes o donde
fueron enterrados el presidente de
brasil they're bolsonaro estaba bajo
presión después de haberse implicado en
un escándalo de corrupción según el cual
se apropió de manera ilegal de salarios
de sus empleados estas acusaciones
fueron publicadas en una serie de
reportes de uno de los principales
portales informativos de internet del
gigante brasileño alimentando una vez
más el llamado a su destitución a través
de un juicio político en el senado
la presión se acumula sobre ya ir
bolsonaro el presidente llegó al poder
en enero de 2019
jurando liberar al país del yugo de la
corrupción y ahora es acusado de liderar
un esquema de desvío de dineros por
parte del sitio web brasileño o el que
publicó una serie de informes y
grabaciones en las que acusa al líder de
derecha de organizar un esquema en el
que tomaba parte del salario de sus
trabajadores mientras ejerció como
legislador de la cámara baja del
congreso entre 1991 y 2008 las
revelaciones han sido rechazadas por la
defensa de bolsonaro que asegura están
basadas en mentiras y hechos que no
existieron pero ya han alentado un
movimiento por la destitución del
presidente de 66 años quien está
enfrentando cada vez más rechazo
ciudadano por su respuesta a la crisis
de el coronavirus que ya ha cobrado más
de medio millón de vidas en el país
suramericano que siguieron a acusaciones
contra integrantes de su gobierno
quienes supuestamente querían
beneficiarse ilegalmente de las compras
de vacunas contra el cob y una
investigación parlamentaria sobre su
manejo de la pandemia se está llevando a
cabo
mientras él niega haber cometido algún
delito su popularidad se ha desvanecido
por encuestas sugiriendo que el ex
presidente de izquierda a luiz inácio
lula da silva lo vencería en la elección
presidencial de 2022 gracias por
acompañarme en esta misión de aquí
américa soy valentina torre sánchez en
la producción giovanni agudelo y natalia
cabrera recuerden que pueden ver este y
otros programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]